- Alright
- Oh I found a hand.
Can I use his hands?
(laughing)
- Yes.
- So today we're gonna
wear some blindfolds,
eat some foods.
Some are vegan, some are not.
We're gonna try to tell the difference.
- Give us some meat, and non-meat.
- You know where my toothpick will be.
- Okay.
- Three, two, one
- Cheers, oh that was pretty good.
- This is tofu.
- That's fake.
They're too soft.
- It doesn't have the stringiness
of a actual chicken.
- This is good, but this is not meat.
- This is definitely meat.
This is all, like, fried.
No, this is fake.
- Wow, I can't tell the difference,
I like this, the second one.
- The second one tasted like flesh,
like there was a soft, flesh vibe.
- This is real chicken?
Is this one?
- Oh, I was right?
Oh yeah.
- Oh, tofu Chicken.
- If this isn't meat,
then anyone can go vegan
because it looks like meat,
it tastes like meat,
and it acts like meat.
- This is just as good as that one.
- The (bleep) is this?
- Is this like, a fake vegan burger?
- It's a burger.
- This is definitely a burger.
- But you can taste the
meat in the after taste.
- I feel like I'm gonna
have diarrhea tonight.
(laughing)
- Vegan.
I actually don't know, no it's vegan.
- It's got vegan cheese on it.
- I do like this one better,
it tastes like it has cheese on it.
- Yeah that is not, that's vegan.
- Wow, plot twist.
- This tasted juicy,
and it's like, not meat
- That had a good sauce on it.
- A for effort on the
vegan side of things,
but come one you can't replace a burger.
- Boy oh boy, oh boy.
- It's so good.
I put the wrong end of
the spoon in my mouth.
(laughing)
- It's falling all over my hand.
- It's ice cream.
- How do I eat this?
- It's supposed to be
cookie dough ice cream.
- It tastes like cinnamon roles.
- I'm like, legit happy that
I just had real ice cream.
- Wait a minute,
I think this tastes vegan.
- This doesn't taste
necessarily like ice cream.
- This is not dairy.
- It's not as good as the first one.
- Again there's a little bitterness.
- Cinnamon-y
- Yeah, it's makin' up for it again.
- Oh, wait what?
- This one's vegan?
- So the first one was vegan?
- Yeah.
What?
- [Together] What?
- No
- Yeah, we ate the Cashew Milk,
and thought it was real.
- No way.
- If you are lactose intolerant
you should eat this, it's delicious,
and if you're not lactose intolerant
you should still eat it.
- He's goin' back in,
He hasn't gone back in this whole time.
Wow.
- What?
- Like from here, now and then
I might try some vegan food options.
- Yeah, I'm more open minded
to experiencing more
vegan food after this.
- It's a good time to be vegan,
there's so many delicious snacks.
- There are, like making me reconsider
some life choices, guys.
- Most of this stuff is
pretty palatable, actually.
The fact that there were some vegan things
that I liked better.
- That I liked more.
I would do this.
I could maybe, maybe give up ice cream.